for years there's only been one way to
make a living playing Smash Brothers the
tournament grind and hungrybox ends the
Armada streak seven years five champion
it was exhausting it's like a mental
battle against myself every single time
I have to practice or do something for
the game right now the prize pools were
garbage
oh I thought maybe Evo how much fun did
you get oh I got $70 oh I guess you get
exposure I guess you got the brand
exposure but like that's it that's
literally all you get and there were a
dozen other incredible players fighting
you for those scraps oh man good
backyard by that go
he's currently you're a doji 2014 super
smash brothers melee zap yeah but what
if your financial future wasn't
dependent on where you live how you
performed on game day or a joke of a
prize pool what if the best smash
players in the world could control their
own destinies you guys have helped me
build this position of where I am today
four years of the competitive smash
circuit has featured an ungodly number
of tournaments in 2004 MLG started
hosting melee turns that attracted the
world's best in large part because they
offered higher prize pools than what you
could get at smaller local tournaments
in 2006 MLG Las Vegas saw the largest
prize pool at the time with $18,000 on
the line congratulations to PC Chris he
came in at beginning of the season
stunned everyone by beating Ken he
outlast everyone else but Super Smash
Bros has always lacked the kinds of
life-changing prize pools that other
eSports get primarily because of
Nintendo's total absence from the
competitive scene seriously look at
every other major eSport even games
smaller than smash get significant dev
support from riot and league of legends
to be soft in Rainbow six siege well
here we have it our very final matchup
of the six Invitational a day that we
have waited for for a long long time
helped even psionics supports rocket
League more than intend Oh supports one
of their biggest franchises they've made
it happen
squishy buffets Torbett gimmick with the
tournament of their lives and don't get
me wrong it's not like the top smash
players don't make any money at all but
there's a problem when the best smash 4
player in the world was only making 40k
a year and everybody else beneath him
wasn't even close and then at some point
I'm like I'm not really enjoying myself
and this is just stressful and I'm not
even making that much money out of it I
just rather do something that's kind of
how I follow the hole and what if your
mango the melee legend has
responsibilities beyond just playing the
game he probably has a decent nest egg
from years of dominating the scene and a
successful streaming career but still
kids are really expensive
[Applause]
both zero and mango have started
stepping back from the tournament scene
just a little and while you'd think that
would cut into their bottom line as
professional smash players the opposite
is actually true streaming has become
key to financial success in Smash ok
we're hosting mangos is this gonna be
good
maybe mostly yeah
we got 6k I got a shroud host yeah uh
any time I read as many viewers it's
always cuz the shroud I was doing fine
by myself I had 1100 playing
winnie-the-pooh so don't try and take
credit for all the shroud Nitra prior to
the release of smash ultimate it was
tough to make a living as a smack
streamer but now with Ultimates
explosion and popularity smash has
joined the ranks of League of Legends
and fortnight as a game with has seen a
large enough to sustain a streaming
career all of a sudden the money that
eluded the best smash players on the
road could be found at home and while
this has proven to be a good thing for
older legends who have retired or slowed
their pace it's also reshape the
competitive landscape
I don't think Armada will enjoy gesture
I think you will I think that for a
while it's gonna be awesome for him I
think just like chillin like a vacation
man mainly stressful like I think it'd
be nice now no one is saying that
streaming is gonna kill competitive
smash people will always play smash
competitively and it's always gonna be
great to watch but the money that
streaming has brought to the table means
that things aren't gonna be the same
anymore
well the competitive circuit will
continue to exist it may not be the
dream for players like MP Leo and
emerging town who like him the
competitive circuit could become a
stepping stone to a successful streaming
career think of it this way as an
up-and-comer the tournament circuit is
where you'd make your name you'd make
some cash and endear yourself to the
smash community and once you've won a
boatload of tournaments the transition
to streaming is always there as a second
fallback career
[Music]
it's become increasingly clear that
streaming full-time not only offers a
viable financial alternative but also
allows you to escape the grueling
tournament schedule but it's a future
filled with as many challenges as
opportunities and that's something that
pro players are gonna have to come to
terms with
I basically do three things that take up
a ton of time that are all full-time
jobs it's one Mele obviously I had to be
one of the best people in the world in
order to get my sponsor to ultimate it
has to be one of the best streamer /
players in the world or I will lose
sponsorships and everything and 3 just
be a streamer which requires me to
stream a crazy amount because if you
don't stream a crazy I'm out then you
lose yours and subs extremely quickly
of course knee prestige tournaments are
still gonna draw the biggest names and
the best talent but as that's how it
grows older and life hands and more
fiscal responsibilities streaming allows
them to do what they love without
running the tournament gauntlet so
champion I've been really thinking about
a new character to me it's a character
that isn't really used often but I'm the
main hall of mark the problem is that
when pros do decide to step back to the
tournament circuit they draw the ire of
fans who feel a sense of ownership over
how their favourite player got to where
they are most adults I've spoken to that
do that are fans of the game and they're
like I don't know they work and they pay
for their own bills
they literally always understand where
I'm coming from because they have to
deal with something like that themselves
it is literally the high school kids and
the middle school kids that don't work
or don't understand what work is and and
bills or taxes hit that they have this
pipe dream dad dude why is your just not
going to every tournament what is he
doing and as a fan I get it we want to
see our favorite players play and play
often the sentiment does come from a
good place
who doesn't want to see the best players
in the world face off on a regular basis
but switch your perspective for just a
second anyone competing on the smash
circuit is in a precarious position it's
either play an absurd amount of
tournaments for the little that comes
with
the best in the world or make a
financially sound decision based on your
family and your future but risk the ire
of the fans who gave you everything I'm
probably going to put a few more
tournaments this year you know just to
appease the fans problem I'm gonna go to
CEO I'm Florida though that's pretty
close to me I'll go to Evo on that I'm
not sure here's the problem let's look
at the zero when he was at his peak he
was collecting a team salary and getting
decent prize money but he was the best
player in the world what happened to the
second best player the third best the
fifth the 10th the smash ecosystem
doesn't have enough money to support the
amount of top players it has and beliefs
not far into the future
I mean 99.9 a competitive players make
make jag bro is just don't make anything
like unless you're the guy went in the
tournament or game consistently second
which most people are not even
consistent in fact some of the best
players that weakest area right now
sometimes they don't even get top aid
half the time that's like what's the
point if you don't even land top a you
don't even make any money at all the
smash community created something worth
celebrating all on their own and they're
even immune to Nintendo turning a cold
shoulder to the competitive scene but
not even smash is immune to the
realities of life like over summit I
probably lost like you know five grands
or more in value for torment I went and
did well at and right now the reality is
that streaming full time allows these
older established pros to do what they
love and entertain the thousands of fans
who've got them where they are today
and we should celebrate that fact
because it means that as the best
smashers can grow and adapt the scene
can - thanks for watching if you want
more great content just like this be
sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]